le designer jiang chen ne pas tondu la
pandémie pour inclure du masque dans
cette collection
j'ai commencé on dit la première fois en
c'était vraiment pour moi justement de
se masquer le visage ça mais aussi
d'inspiration orientale coréenne
japonaise
on ne la mode pas de demain la semaine
prochaine la modifie sur ce depuis le
début de la pandémie
il rejoint une nouvelle clientèle et ses
ventes sont en forte hausse
le designer denis gagnon s'est lui aussi
lancé dans la fabrication de masques
veut plus sourire des gens vos pulls et
les gens avec les belles d'ange comme le
rouge à lèvres que les femmes peuvent se
mettre alors je me suis dit pourquoi pas
agrément agrémenter un pull les masses
et leur donner une couleur leur donner
une vie leur donner une lumière une
façon pour le designer de pallier le
ralentissement dans le monde de la mode
les masques en ce moment c'est vraiment
pour nous une belle à une ressource
financière parce que ça nous permet de
survivre dans cette pandémie
qu'on veuille ou non les masques
pourrait bien être la tendance mode de
l'année
l'engouement est planétaire et les prix
s'envolent je pense à celui de foued que
beaucoup fait parler qui est une marque
de streetwear et donc de vêtements si on
veut décontractée existence en dollars
us et donc eu beaucoup fait jaser ah
parce que c'était le lis tes mode à se
procurer pendant la pandémie
pour sa part le designer net une kong a
bénéficié d'un coup de pouce de manière
inattendue le masque je porte
aujourd'hui été fabriqués par le
designer natenco je suis très très
content que ex-agent de cette surprise
pour moi
après des études en biologie n'est
qu'une kong s'est tourné vers le monde
de la mode
les motifs des imprimés de ces masques
de soi sont conçues par des artistes
atteints de troubles de santé mentale et
10% des revenus sont versés à la
fondation les impatients
reste à voir si le port du masque se
généralisera je pense que chez nous oui
encore un peu de méfiance le couvre
visage est encore un peu étrange et pas
du tout intégré à nos habitudes
donc je pense que ça risque de prendre
un certain temps mais je serais pas
étonné qu'à long terme
ça soit à intégrer éventuellement comme
je vais peut-être au même titre que la
cravate mais je pense qu'on est
absolument pas rendu là une chose est
sûre des créateurs inspirés transforme
en objet de nécessité en bel accessoire
apporter ici nabi alexandre chartier
radio canada montréal